quand on m'a proposé de venir faire une
présentation ici de venir vous parler
j'ai tout d'abord refusé en me disant
qu'en tant que jeune je n'étais pas
tellement légitime a diffusé un message
c'est vrai mieux vaut laisser sa place à
un professionnel qui aura vraiment vécu
des choses très intéressantes et qui
aura le recul nécessaire pour parler des
expériences et puis je me suis dit que
justement le manque de recul
ça peut être une force l'entrée dans la
vie active des jeunes
l'ambition chez les jeunes l'échec et la
persévérance
chez les jeunes sont des thèmes touche
mon entourage au jour le jour et moi
même par la même occasion car je sais ça
se voit pas mais je suis jeune ce que
vous m'avez vu rentrer et où vous êtes
diois encore un vieux et non non je
rigole mais ici au canada en tout cas
vous avez un jeune qui est fantastique
plus que ça même c'est xavier dolan
alors je pense que vous le connaissez
tous pour sa filmographie est entre
autres et c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
énormément aidé et inspiré sans même
qu'ils le sachent
la première manche forcément pour sa
filmographie mais aussi pour une petite
phrase qu'il a prononcée lorsqu'il a
reçu son prix le prix du jury du
festival de cannes 2014
je pense que tout est possible a qui
rêvent aux travail et n'abandonne jamais
c'est tout con mais cette petite phrase
aussi simple soit elle m'a bord et
d'optimisme à recharger mon cerveau
parce que xavier dolan prouve au jour le
jour qu'on peut se bouger le cul pour de
bonnes raisons avant même de pouvoir
regarder du porno légalement qui prouve
que la filmo que de filmer la
réalisation n'est pas qu'une histoire de
vieux barbu et pour ma part c'est
jouissif parce que je n'ai pas de barbe
qui prouve aussi que l'âge n'est pas
garant de génie et je peux vous dire que
ça fait du bien et
il faut se dire aussi une chose c'est
que cette petite phrase peut avoir un
impact énorme et ce fut le cas sûrement
je pense que tout est possible a qui
rêvent aux travail et n'abandonne jamais
mais c'est génial je pense que
tout est possible tout est possible a
qui rêvent hausse travail et n'abandonne
jamais c'est à dire que si on travaille
on ose on rêve et bat tout est possible
c'est bien non moi ça m'a ça va booster
un asama chauffer tout d'abord rêvé
c'est la génèse tout est possible
lorsque l'on rêve le rêve tous
l'ambition à se créer et pour que cette
ambition se durcissent se consolide et
bien il faut croire en ses rêves
alors ça crée une sorte de cercle oui
c'est comme ça que je représente le
cercle c'est un peu ridicule
si je le fais très longtemps ça devient
très ridicule ça crée une sorte de
cercle qui peut paraître facile à faire
réaliser mais je pense que c'est pas si
facile que ça justement antoine de
saint-exupéry disait fais de ta vie un
rêve et d'un rêve une réalité
alors posons les choses tout de suite il
a les rêves ont fait lorsque l'on dort
celui où il embrasse julia roberts et le
rêve que l'on fait éveillé la projection
vous savez c'est ce qu'on fait quand on
est paumé qu'on a les yeux dans le vide
quand on a un petit sourire en coin
comme des cons parce qu'ils s'imaginent
un avenir radieux
eh bien c'est ce rêve dont je parle et
pour que ce rêve devienne ambitions
c'est à l'individu lui-même de se dire
que oui c'est possible que ce ne soit
pas qu'un rêve pour toute ma vie et
c'est aussi deuxièmement à l'entourage
de cet individu donc conditionné de le
motiver de lui dire mais warning à la
fin alors tu as fait mais tu peux y
arriver
et du coup comme je vous disais pour
passer du rêve à l'ambition j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut une petite
étincelle et cette petite étincelle
pense que la confiance en soi l'aide à
se créer et vous le savez mieux que moi
la confiance en soi ça tient parfois à
rien du tout je me souviens au collège
d'un professeur qui s'appelait monsieur
lacombe un mec plutôt stock de médecins
quelques une petite barbe et c'est un
prof de maths et il nous disait en début
d'année essayer de résoudre ce problème
et puis au bout de trois mois je ne sais
pas pourquoi est ce parce qu'il a fait
il a commencé à nous dire on verra en
combien de temps vous trouverez la
solution
et puis qui recule parce que malgré mon
jeune âge arrive à avoir un peu de recul
sur ce que j'effectue au collège et là
je suis un con il n'est plus exercice de
la même manière dans le premier cas
monsieur lacombe nous parle de problèmes
dans la ce dans la seconde phrase elle
nous parle de solutions dans le premier
cas il nous demande d'essayer dans le
second il nous dit qu'on va réussir
c'est tout con c'est vrai merci pour
votre interactions rica en tout cas ça
motive à fond et le rêve c'est la génèse
l'ambition et le moteur et pour créer
son plan d'action il faut attendez c'est
prévu aux et c'est times et un rosé ce
n'est pas facile d'oser je ne suis pas
sûr que de nature l'homme aux je pense
que l'homme se complaît très facilement
c'est mon point de vue et c'est un
danger il ne faut pas que c'est les
élites aux sinon c'est pas drôle
chacun peut oser et doit oser selon sa
propre mesure selon ses propres envies
ses propres moyens par exemple déjà osé
dire non
as tu feras le même boulot papa et maman
si on n'a pas envie et déjà quelque
chose d'assez lourd et conséquent à
faire d'ailleurs par rapport à sa petite
petite parenthèse comme ça pour les
parents qui en a ce soir qui ont la
manie de vouloir imposer leur passion
leur travail leurs enfants vous voyez le
film billy elliot
regardez le voilà je vous dis ça comme
ça je vous dis ça comme ça vous le
regardez vous aimez ou pas on s'en fout
vous prenez message ces trous et âme à
petit et ça je me souviens avec quelques
années de cela j'ai j'osais loupé des
cours et me confronter un petit peu mes
parents pour aller interviewer des stars
sur la capitale française paris ça me
paraît maintenant dérisoire mais à
l'époque c'était
quelque chose aux et dépassé son univers
découvrir de nouvelles choses pour les
jeunes c'est compliqué mais nécessaire
et mon univers à l'époque et celui de
nombreux jeunes aujourd'hui se résume à
école maison bus internet facebook
twitter snapshot instagram youporn
youtube du pardon tu portes
je ne connais pas je sais un site de
cuisine je connais tu sais pas ce que ça
m'est venu comme ça osez découvrir aux
et expérimenté osé se faire confiance
oser aller dans le chemin qu'on veut se
créer c'est se différencier des autres
opposés c'est un petit peu se mettre en
danger je pense aux et c'est perdre ses
repères
tandis que ne rien faire c'est être sûr
de ce qu'on fera demain et pour oser il
ya un bel avantage c'est le courage
comme disait claude nougaro un fameux
jazzman français
j'ai du coeur mais pas d'estomac et je
pense que l'estomac il en faut un petit
peu pour oser prenons l'analogie de tony
ce pote au collège qu'on a tous eu je
pense que tu l'as eu tony c'était le mec
un peu style est un peu plus grand que
les autres qui écouter du rock à la
craie qui avait une petite crête et une
chaîne en or bon on le déteste ou on le
détestait tous pourquoi parce qu'ils
sortaient que toutes les filles alors
que nous on passait nos soirées sûr sur
youtube
alors de quoi on avait peur de l'inconnu
la fille on avait peur de faire un pas
vers elle de se prendre un vent d'être
la risée du value bonds le temps a passé
je ne suis plus au collège depuis bien
longtemps environ deux semaines
il ne paraît maintenant et s'il vous
plaît et il me paraît maintenant évident
que toni avait raison il fallait
surpasser et sauter cette barrière qui
n'était que psychologique et oser dire
salut mélanie oui j'avais des bagues à
l'époque évoqué ça va c'est du mail ni
c'est panayotis à 98 pas nouveau on est
à côté ensemble en classe depuis deux
ans quand même donc c'est pas grave je
voulais te dire tu ressemble vachement
atelier roberge
oui c'était ma technique de drague ok je
pensais que dire à une fille tu
ressembles à julia roberts était ce la
mettre dans la poche mais non c'est pas
grave
en tout cas la drague c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut travailler et vous avez
vu les aides et transitions sont pas mal
j'ai travaillé là tu as travaillé ce qui
est le plus important ce qui va être
déterminant s'était pas de travailler
tout le monde le fait c'est de savoir
pourquoi on travaille
pourquoi on fait tout ça quel est le
sens derrière tout ça trouver un but à
tous ces efforts est une des priorités
je pense alors je parle pas du travail
le week-end où travaille un petit peu le
week-end pour pour faire un peu de
thunes le travail au sens concret et non
je vous parle du travail qui a un sens
profond celui qui va vous apporter
expérience confiance en soi c'est celui
qui va peut-être pas avoir un impact
concret et direct sur votre compte en
banque mais qui va vous apporter quelque
chose de bien plus important de mes 12 à
mes 15 ans qui a pas longtemps j'ai
réalisé une vingtaine d'interviews et au
début c'était très contraignant je ne
sortais pas le week-end avec mes amis
parce que j'avais du montage à faire je
me couchais tard parce que j'avais du
montage à faire je n'avais pas de petite
copine parce que j'étais nul en drag et
je voulais bien peu plus tôt mais d'un
autre côté ça m'importait bon nombre de
compétences qu'elle soit technique
utilisé une caméra montée unique
s'étalonner qu'elle soit sociale avec le
développement de mon tact avec les gens
de ma confiance en moi
l'enrichissement mon carnet d adresses
je me suis fait bon nombre d'amis avec
qui j'ai toujours la chance de
travailler en ce moment ça m'a aussi
l'après g ça m'a aussi ma phrase n'a pas
de sens ça m'a aussi appris à gérer mon
stress c'est mieux à apprendre à gérer
des fortes responsabilités à acquérir le
sens des priorités par exemple comme mon
premier cachet de comédiens est tombé
parce que oui je suis comédien des fois
quand mon premier cachet de comédiens
est tombé sans hésiter tout de suite je
me suis acheté un mac pour aller sur
youtube le soir est aussi une suite de
logiciels de montage pour me
perfectionner dans montage et c'est à
partir de ce moment précis que j'ai
commencé à orienter tous mes choix
même les plus anodins en fonction de ma
passion et mon travail c'était pas
contraignant c'était un plaisir et
travail et trouver un but derrière tout
ça c'est le primordial je pense c'est
quelque chose de primordial travail est
en cours
ok pourquoi pas mais si on sait pourquoi
on travaille en cours au lycée
si on sait que ce n'est pas forcément du
temps qu'on passe à travailler sur des
choses qui nous intéresse peut-être pas
à fond mais qu'on se dit que c'est un
pari sur notre avenir
assane thiam on voit plus ça comme du
temps perdu on voit ça comme quelque
chose pourtant pour se construire un bel
avenir et maintenant on arrive et on a
osé on a travaillé il reste une chose à
faire qui n'est pas des moindres c'est
ne pas abandonner mais pas abandonnée on
rencontre et c'est normal sur ce fameux
chemin cette ascension de plus en plus
d'obstacles qui affaiblissent la petite
flamme en ou alors des obstacles petit
ou grand moi j par assas bras j'ai pas
énormément d'expérience donc j'ai pas
encore vécu et rencontré de gros
obstacles
j'ai touche du bois on a ici je touche
du bois pour ne pas rencontrer de gros
mais pour l'instant j'en ai rencontré
deux petits forcément et ses obstacles
affaibli cette petite flamme en août qui
nous disaient mais oui tu peux devenir
chirurgienne
mais oui tu peux devenir basketteur mais
oui tu peux devenir médecin mais oui tu
peux devenir qu'il est mais oui tu peux
devenir figurant dans tous les films de
julia roberts pour espérer de la pêche
ou à la fin des tournages pardon ça
c'était pour moi mais c'était voilà
c'est ma passion julia roberts est
magnifique le risque est que cette
petite flamme s'éteigne et que l'on
oublie qu'on s'était dit à la base quand
on avait rêvé de devenir chirurgienne et
quand c'était dit c'est bien d'être
chirurgienne qu'on avait travaillé pour
devenir chirurgienne qu'on avait avant
oser se dire c'est possible et c'est pas
parce qu'on a tué de trois patients
qu'il faut arrêter bon c'est peut-être
pas le bon exemple
ok c'est pas le bon exemple je m'excuse
mais quoiqu elle si ça va j'aime bien
cet exemple mais mais en tout cas pour
ne pas abandonner pour entretenir cette
flamme de la motivation de l'ambition je
peux vous proposer une petite chose qui
m'a énormément aidé qui m'a boosté c'est
de rencontrer ses idoles ou les
personnes qui sont influentes dans notre
univers dans l'univers dans lequel on
veut rentrer pour ma part ce fut ce
fameux jeune réalisateur xavier dolan
que j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer une
heure après son fameux discours vous
savez je pense que tout est possible a
qui rêvent aux vient de cracher un truc
énorme
a qui rêvent hausse travail c'est pas
grave et tout le monde donne jamais
faudra peut-être les plus fous pour le
solide après c'est pas la route et j'ai
eu la merde j'ai eu la chance de le
rencontrer une heure après ce fameux
discours est donc gelé vu dans un
couloir
j'avais réussi à me faire inviter au
festival de cannes en envoyant de trois
mails une centaine environ au comité
d'accréditation pour qu'ils m'invitent
et je pense qu'ils en avaient marre de
recevoir un mail toutes les 30 minutes
sont sûrs d'y aller le petit on l'invite
donc j'ai la chance de le croiser dans
ce fameux couloir une impression
discours j'ai voulu faire le mec un peu
confiants cheval et loire je dis bonjour
panayotis alors qu'en grèce à ccc est la
moins de trois mètres au fut
comme si tu le vois pas un c'est comme
si tu salut bonjour
et donc j'ai fait le mec un petit peu je
suis rarement genre saviez un métis et
on a discuté et pour moi c'était une
discussion magistral fantastique j'étais
sur un petit nuage
pour lui ça devait être une discussion
banale mais je m'en foutais on a discuté
et 10 minutes et je me souviens qu'à la
fin de cette discussion super
intéressante et enrichissante
il est parti et je la regardais
correspond comme ça et je venais
d'oublier tout ce que j'avais vécu les
petits obstacles j'avais rencontré avant
c'est-à-dire des castings loupé des vues
qui ne décollait pas sur mes vidéos des
vidéos qui ne sortait même pas des
problèmes à l'école parce que je devais
louper les cours pour faire des petites
vidéos etc tout ça c'était oublié
c'était parti il n'avait qu'une petite
chose en tête c'était c'est vrai c'est
pour ça que j'ai envie de faire ce
métier c'est pour ça que j'ai
envie de faire ce de métier et du
coup j'avais un grand sourire et j'étais
prêt à repartir pour trois ans encore
dans cette personne le chemin pour
essayer d'arriver à mon but et comme je
suis quand même un peu pro je les
rattraper et vu que mon but c'est qu'on
tienne confrères aux collègues je lui
laissais ma carte de visite pas du tout
j'ai fait à cette fille voilà bon chacun
son truc
les jeunes c'est le cfi en tout cas il y
à une deuxième petite chose dont
j'aimerais vous parler
bonjour c
as tu croyais pas qu'il ait la moindre
interaction 1 est malin il n'y a pas de
mur ici loquet si je veux te parler de
pression et il ya une douzaine petites
choses aussi dont je peux vous parler
c'est d'approfondir sa connaissance du
domaine dans lequel les mots dans lequel
on veut évoluer pour ma part a la base
je voulais être comédien mais j'ai testé
de faire de la réalisation de l'écriture
de sketches de la mise en scène etc
et qu'est ce qui me donne plus envie de
manger un gâteau que de faire des allers
retours devant la vitrine il ya un
dernier petit point oui il ya beaucoup
de points dans cette partie je me suis
un peu lâché sur cette partie j'ai dû
aller on va faire pleins poumons
le dernier petit point qui m'a
énormément aidé aussi c'est de
relativiser la notion d'échec et de
réussite
à l'époque et je côtoie beaucoup de
jeunes qui pensent comme ça je me disais
qu'il y avait deux voies la voie de la
réussite et la voie de l'échec
c'est faux je pense qu'il ya qu une
seule voie qui mène
s'il on persévère à la réussite avec un
grand r c'est à dire que cet unique voie
comporte des petits échecs des petites
réussites et ses échecs et réussites des
petits échecs des petites réussites et
faut pas s'arrêter au premier échec en
disant je tombais dans la voie des
chèques non c'est faux faux poursuivant
faut continuer et sur cette fameuse voix
pour reprendre cette métaphore quasi
spirituelle
on rencontre pour nombre de personnes
qui nous aident à continuer qui nous
tiennent la main et qui nous donne ou
redonne cette petite étincelle qui la
voit dans nos yeux et c'est vrai qu'une
réussite ça se ressent aussi dans le
regard des autres se former une clique
une team travaille avec des gens en
adéquation parfaite c'est quelque chose
que j'ai eu la chance de vivre et je
peux vous dire que quand vous traîner
avec des cerveaux qui ont la même
ambition de vous et qui voit cette
fameuse voie de la même manière que vous
eh bien ça vaut peut-être dix cerveaux
qui regarde dans tous les sens pour
terminer j'aimerais vous partagez le
conseil
le meilleur conseil que j'ai reçu de de
ma vie je pense même elle écourte encore
je pars à sibiu que ça mais je vais
quand même dire de ma vie pour faire
mixte il est le meilleur conseil que
j'ai reçu ma vie c'est pas le conseil le
plus académique
j'ai pu recevoir mais c'est le conseil
qui m'a le plus marqué quand j'avais 11
12 ans j'ai interviewé orelsan qui est
un des rappeurs les plus connus en
france et j'étais super content
l'interview s'était bien passé j'avais
juste oublié d'allumer le micro mais du
coup la moitié de la haye ça va un peu
un ça va
et puis du coup la moité de l'interview
était parti à la poubelle on avait
réussi à récupérer du son avec des
iphone c'était un peu la merde et je me
souviens que j'avais terminé le montage
l'avait montré mon père et il m'avait
regardé et m'a dit tu t'es fort elle un
bon respire un bon coup travail un bon
coup la prochaine fois tu feras mieux
merci d'avoir écouté un jeune